I'm very happy to introduce Adam Boland
Adam Lowe tell us something seemingly a
little different than what we've heard
before about demography but it's still
exploring this this phenomenon of
exponential complexity of quantum states
but this time having to do with alright
great yeah thanks so much for the
introduction so I'll be telling you
today about pseudo randomness and the a
DSC T a DSC of T correspondence and this
is all based on joint work with Bill
Fefferman and mesh buzzer ah so the
starting point for this talk is a
somewhat strange question it is could
quantum circuit complexity be physical
that is could circuit complexity be a
measurable quantity like heat or light
or distance or time and at first glance
this sounds like a somewhat strange
question to a computer scientist but
believe it or not there's actually been
a proposal that circuit complexity is
physical in the context of black hole
physics this idea that circuit
complexities physical emerged out of
something called the it from cubic
collaboration which is us another
Simon's foundation collaboration but
this one on quantum gravity and this is
a giant collaboration with 17p eyes
across many different institutions and
the context for this proposal that
circuit complexities physical really
lies in one of the central challenges of
20th century physics which has been the
challenge to try to create a unified
theory which simultaneously reconciles
quantum mechanics and gravity now it
turns out that actually formulating a
unified theory of quantum gravity has
been extraordinarily difficult for
physicists and this is due to several
obstructions the first is certain
paradoxes that arise when you consider
how quantum mechanics interacts with
gravity in the presence of black holes
maybe you've heard of
walking's quantum information
paradoxical this goes back to the 60s
but on top of that there's also the
sheer mathematical challenge of how you
combine two very different looking
theories that speak different
mathematical languages now one kind of
glimmer of hope in this class to create
a theory of quantum gravity has been
something called the ABS CFT
correspondence of mole the same ax and
this has been really one of the most
central attempts to construct the theory
of quantum gravity to give you an idea
of just how central this is you know
this paper to date has over 18,000
citations from the last 20 years alright
so what why our physics are so excited
about this well the reason is that this
a DSC of T correspondence you can view
it as kind of a recipe for constructing
a theory of quantum gravity okay so what
do I mean by that let's unpack this
correspondence a bit so what the
correspondence is is it's a conjecture
duality between a quantum gravity theory
which is living on this left-hand theory
and a quantum mechanical theory which
lives on the right-hand now it turns out
that the quantum gravity theory happens
to lie in something called anti the
center space and the type of quantum
mechanical theory is something called a
conformal field theory this is where the
name comes from but just think of it as
the simple duality between a gravity
theory on the left that's the object we
want and the quantum mechanical theory
on the right now what do physicists mean
when they say this is a duality well
what they mean is that there is some
dictionary that map's States in one
theory to States in the other theory and
operators in one theory to operators and
the other theory so think of these as
being like you know there's two Hilbert
spaces and there's some sort of map that
takes States and one to the other and
the idea is that this dictionary is some
sort of homomorphism between the
theories so
you can see now why physicists are so
excited about this duality the reason is
you can view this duality is a recipe
for constructing a theory of quantum
gravity by studying its dual qualit
inferi so in other words if you can just
understand the quantum theory on the
right and look at its image under this
dictionary map that then is a recipe for
giving you a quantum gravity theory this
object that everyone has been searching
for you know the last the last a hundred
years or so
now this correspondence is not something
that has been fully worked out I would
say that the dictionary is kind of under
construction in some sense and what I
mean by this is that they have several
examples of different states that are
dual to particular states in each theory
but there's not a general like
well-defined your mathematical
construction that just you know allows
you to compute this dictionary it's
rather something that's been kind of
calculated for specific and structured
instances okay now one challenge that
has arisen in trying to construct this a
DSC of P correspondence is something
called the wormhole growth paradox which
was first identified by Susskind back in
2014 and while this paradox I'm sounds
very scary it's actually it's fairly
simple to state in quantum mechanical
terms so this paradox involves kind of
the following conundrum so if you look
at gravity theories gravitational
theories admit certain solutions to
Einstein's equations which are called
wormholes
these wormholes are basically it's a
black hole
that connects two distant regions of
space-time they're actually not
connected to one another and the unique
property of wormholes is that they are
objects in general relativity which
never equilibrate namely in particular
they do not equilibrate for at least an
exponential amount of time so
what do I mean by that well what happens
with this wormhole is that if you
naturally time evolved it the throat of
the wormhole kind of stretches and
shrinks and what happens is that the
volume of the world as this interior
space in between the two separate
universes grows linearly with time now
in classical general relativity this
growth actually continues indefinitely
of course we know once this is living in
a quantum theory it will have to stop at
some point because the hilbert space is
finite but just think of this as a
theory that really never equilibrates on
the other hand the quantum mechanical
theory on the right-hand side is
believed to have a very different sort
of equilibrium property in particular
this quantum mechanical theory very
rapidly equilibrates you should think of
as being something like a blender that
very rapidly scrambles quantum
information so to make this a little
more precise if you say take a local
operator oh and you look at you know
what's the expectation value of this
local operator o of the states over time
as you type of on loop on mechanical
theory when you end up finding is that
it equilibrate sperry rapidly so it just
saturates the kind of its limiting value
in a time which scales say polynomial e
in the number of qubits in the system
okay so this is a bit weird this is
saying there's some sort of mismatch
between the equilibrium properties of
the theories and this is precisely this
paradox that Susskind then asked
Susskind asked what quantity on the
right hand side then could possibly be
the dual quality to wormhole on you
right if you believe this dictionary
exists you know there's this fool
homomorphisms between the theories so
everything on the left-hand side should
have a dual on the right-hand side so
what what could be the dual two-volume
what's what's a quantity of the
right-hand side state that that should
grow a time in the same way as boolean
and we know that it can't be any locally
defined quality because those things
just equilibria to rapidly
okay so this was the wormhole growth
paradox and in the same paper in which
Susskind identified this paradox he also
proposed a solution to the paradox in
particular his proposed solution was
that circuit complexity is physical in
particular he conjectured that the dual
to wormhole value is literally the
circuit complexity of the dual quantum
state that has to say the minimum number
of gates needed to prepare the state
starting from some reference state okay
so this is a very creative proposal and
it's it's worthwhile kind of example
thing what was the intuition for
proposing this as the dual oh yeah I
should also mention this proposed
duality is usually called the complexity
equals volume conjecture because it's
conjecturing the complexity of the
right-hand theory is dual to the volume
of the left-hand theory so it's helpful
to understand Susskind intuition for
positing this as the dual and you know
the intuition here went something like
this
so these states are all evolving
according to some Hamiltonian H and you
know the state of the system on the
right hand side at time T you know is
given by the usual time evolution of the
system just e to the IH T times some
initial States I would just say the
initial state corresponding to a
wormhole of 0 volume at time 0 so you
can think of this of this evolution with
time is just applying some fixed unitary
U to the state over and over again so
Susskind intuition was that the
complexity of the state relative to the
initial state should grow linearly with
time essentially because there shouldn't
be any shortcuts to preparing this state
other than just applying u you know many
many times to the initial state so
that's the intuition here now there's
going to actually some work trying to
provide supporting evidence that this is
that this could be a a reasonable
conjecture so friend
since there was some interesting
complexity work of Aaronson and brandão
baba knowit's and Balasubramanyam at all
which showed that basically you know it
is plausible that for certain unit Ares
you or Hamiltonians ages that the
complexity of the States should grow at
some rate with time of course under
certain complexity theoretic assumptions
similarly there have been some works on
the gravity side as well by Stanford and
Susskind Stamper and Schanker and others
who tried to show that some of the
behavior of the volume mimics what
happens on the complexity side as well
and I'll discuss this evidence a bit
more but that's kind of a the state of
evidence for this conjecture now in
evaluating this proposed solution as a
computer scientist you know this
solution might strike one that's
somewhat strange because as computer
scientists we know that circuit
complexity is a very subtle quantity to
try to pin down you know if if circuit
complexity very easy you know we already
would have shown NP is not in P slash
poly and moreover we know that there are
certain barriers to you know say
suffering fevers NP which actually tell
you that circuit complexity is something
that's very difficult to feel or
estimate so it seems strange to be
equated circuit complexity with a kind
of very physical quantity like the
volume of a wormhole alright so let's
see if we can formalize this computer
scientists that's comfort a bit more
carefully I think the best way of
understanding that that says you know
this discomfort is really that there
seems to be some sort of type mismatch
between complexity and volume so
negatively on the one hand you know
circuit complexity is something that
should be very difficult to feel or
estimate right this is our intuition
coming from you know the study of
computational pseudo randomness which
I'll bring up in the moment and the
second
the source of our discomfort in this I
know this wormhole volume sounds like
something that should be easy to
estimate like okay if sounds like
something like naively you should be
able to jump in the wormhole and just
kind of get out your tape measure and
then kind of measure the wormhole volume
so it seems like something that's that
has a very different property namely and
iodides easy to estimate so it seems
that these properties are a bit
mismatched across this duality but turns
out that formalizing this discomfort is
surprisingly tricky this is for kind of
two reasons the first is that only a
very special subset of quantum states
are being considered in this in this
particular conjecture it's not you say
all quantum states on that hilbert space
you know it could be that the complexity
of these states that they're talking
about is somehow easier to estimate then
for generic quantum states right so that
would kind of be an obstruction to
fertilizing this discomfort there's a
moreover there's a second obstruction
which is coming a bit more from the
physics side which is that no single
observer in the black hole can actually
estimate the volume so there actually is
no way in which a person can jump into
the wormhole you take out the tape
measure and kind of measure how big it
is inside the wormhole and then then
give the answer this is due to certain
constraints and general relativity which
basically say that once you jump into
the wormhole you die in some constant
amount of time so you don't have enough
time to kind of performing the
experiment that would allow you to to to
measure this one whole thing
so maybe the second quality is something
that's inaccessible as well so in this
work what we did is we started with this
discomfort and we asked you know can
these objections be realized in this
model and the so what would this mean
for the a DSC of T correspondence and
this is precisely what I addressed in
joint work of Bill pfefferman in English
buzzer awfully last year in particular
we showed two results so
our first result is that we created a
form of computational pseudo randomness
in this dual quantum theory as in this
tiny subset of states that are being
addressed by this complexity equals
volume conjecture and the basic idea
here is that what we ended up creating
is some sort of ensemble of states
within this domain of Eleni of the
conjecture which are extremely difficult
to distinguish from one another but with
have which have very different wormhole
volumes right now an interesting aspect
of this construction is that it actually
applies to any quantity that grows with
time so what what do I mean by this well
once you have a pseudo-random
misconstruction it actually implies not
only that the circuit complexity of
these states is hard to estimate but
moreover any quality that measure is
kind of how long you've acted on the
state is also something that's difficult
to measure as well so what this means is
that this sooner randomness barrier that
we're creating is not just an obstacle
to having circuit complexity as the goal
but it's actually an obstacle to to any
quantity you would posit as the dual
two-volume and this was something that
maybe surprised us when when we were
going through this work we maybe
initially thought that you know because
the pseudorandomness thing was going to
only affect circuit complexity at all
it turns out it's much more general than
that so this means that somehow this
discomfort we're feeling about positing
circuit complexity is a dual is
inevitable it's not something that that
one can escape by kind of just picking a
different dual quantity the second
argument is that we showed that the
wormhole volume is something that is
easy to compute now this is when I say
easy to compute I mean this is kind of a
little more general of a setting
actually arguing the ball volume is easy
to compute requires combining the
experiences of many different observers
who live in the world
and kind of post-processing what they
saw in order to to kind of infer the the
volume of the wormhole from there kind
of collective or aggregate experience so
now from a computational side you know
this is something that makes sense you
know like you can run different quantum
experiments and post process results you
know this is you know an efficient model
of computation so but you know this is
kind of a non physical experiment and
lack the wormhole things experience that
you know the observers whose experiences
experiencing we are experiences we are
combining are not people who kind of
talk to one another physically within
the theory so kind of the volume here is
easy to compute in a computational sense
even though it's kind of physically
inaccessible so that look let's listen
to Nate and Irish yes polynomial a many
observers yes
that's a good question the number
observers will end up being just kind of
proportional to the length of the
wormholes we're talking about but and in
all of these constructions everything
will be in polynomial time so we aren't
talking about very late time wormholes
these are in wormholes I have only
evolved for a relatively short amount of
time yeah that's a good question and the
parameter here is like in the room you
said the length of the wormhole yeah
yeah the number observers you need ends
up being and yet in some sense
proportional to the length of the
wormhole but the yeah things things are
a bit more subtle than that but I think
that that's the overall picture it kind
of them it depends a little bit on how
you imagine this quantum gravity state
encoding the bulk geometry this is kind
of taking a very conservative position
where you say okay I have no idea what a
DSC FP looks like but should it's sure
that at least tell me what would happen
to you know a single observer like you
know you might hope that it's more
general that it allows you to
reconstruct the entire space
you know like the way you would simulate
gr and the quantum computer like you
know where you say could learn the
metric at every point in space you know
if if that were the case if a DSC if P
encode the geometry in that more general
way that you would only need one copy
and the second part of our argument
might might not be might not be
necessary okay great so I'll get to
these arguments in a little more detail
soon but let me just quickly tell you
kind of what this means for a DSC ft so
you know the first front of our results
argued that kind of you know whatever
this dual quantity to volume is it has
to be something that's really difficult
to compute you know something like
complexity and here we mean
exponentially difficult to compute even
with a quantum computer on the other
hand we argued that if you had the
gravity state on the left-hand side the
wormhole ball you would be relatively
easy to compute that means that you know
in other words it would be computable in
polynomial time given access to a pawn
computer so what does this imply well
this implies that this dictionary map is
reducing a problem that's very hard on
the right hand side to a problem that's
very easy on the right hand so on the
left hand side right so that means you
know something here has to be doing that
the heavy lifting so particularly this
means that this dictionary itself then
must be exponentially difficult to
compute you know this would be like you
know if you gave a reduction from you
know three sacks and you showed that
Freesat is reducible to a problem that's
in pea you know okay yeah possibly you
could have shown P equals NP but more
likely you made a mistake and somewhere
in your reduction you know you
accidentally perform some exponential
time computation this is kind of what's
going on here because this is this
duality is reducing a hard problem to an
easy problem all right now what this
means for a DSC of T kind of in general
and kind of interpreting this result
is something that I'm going to address
more in detail at the end but I just
wanted to give you a quick flavor of
kind of where we're going with this so
that you're kind of able to see kind of
what's how the argument is stitching
together to get some some conclusion
about the complexity of ABS CFD so in
some sense yeah so you could you could
say that our result might be saying this
dictionary is permanently under
construction in the sense that yeah you
know it will be possible to compute for
you know individual states or you know
particular structured instances but this
general dictionary should be something
that should be extremely difficult to
work out ok so now my remaining time I'm
going to try to do some of the key ideas
that go into this argument in particular
I'm going to try to explain to you the
ways in which we establish pseudo
randomness within the domain of validity
of this conjecture in the CFT and this
is a very interesting kind of argument
because it ends up bringing together a
lot of different notions both from
classical computer science and pseudo
randomness and also from cryptography
actually it turns out that block ciphers
will play a role in establishing our
pseudo randomness argument all right all
right so in order to try to establish
pseudo randomness for the CFT States we
first need to understand what states are
we allowed in the CFT to begin with so
what is this kind of domain the validity
of this conjecture so in order to
understand this we're going to start
with a toy model in which we're going to
model the CFT as a system of n qubits
where n is the entropy of the black hole
now it's true that a conformal field
theory is not naturally a theory that
is the tensor product a few minutes you
know back actually has it's an
uncountable infinite dimensional we make
a very concrete model so that that we
can then argue about it more more
specifically and this particular model
is something that has already been used
in the 80s CFD literature so the initial
state of our system and the C of T is a
special state called the thermal field
doubles state which we need to know T FD
and this is a low energy state of the
Hamiltonian so it's not an eigenstate
but it's a state that's you know it's
expected value of its energy is
relatively low now the the structure of
the state is not very important for our
arguments so let's just say for the
moment that is just some state that's
relatively easy to prepare
now this some state this special state T
FD evolves chording according to the CFT
hamiltonian so this is kind of the son
of states that are allowed in the CFT if
we want to look at it in this
discretized picture you know it turns
out that this this Hamiltonian and has
an additional special property which is
that this hamiltonian is believed to be
scrambling which is to say there's some
characteristic time scale T naught such
that after evolution for time T naught
you know this this Hamiltonian kind of
diffuses local perturbations throughout
the system so let's just call evolution
by scrambling time you so the states and
the theory you know you know just with
normal time evolution or just you know
you just apply you over and over again
to this initial State now formulating
complexity equals volume for just these
states you know seems like a very kind
of narrow theory so actually complex
equals volume is formulated for a bit of
a more general subset of states namely
be the evolution that's also allowed
sorry I don't know why the animations
not working but
this evolution can be perturbed by
inserting some small number L of single
qubit gates into the evolution and the
idea is that each insertion of a one
qubit gate you know would increase the
energy of the state by some small amount
say assuming this Hamiltonian H CFT is
local and what these local one qubit
gates in the CFT correspond to is these
correspond to shocks in the gravity
theory which kind of are what these
shocks do is they throw energy into the
whirlpool so these are sometimes called
shocks or shock waves that were applying
to the state so what we end up giving is
some some state that looks like the
following we start with the T FD we
evolved for a scrambling time we then
apply a one qubit gate oh one we then
evolve by you again we apply another one
qubit gate oh 2 etc etc and let's say we
do the cell x so what these states are
is you know they're basically like the
normal time evolution which is what you
obtained by just applying you many times
the initial state but you're allowed to
make some perturbations in this circuit
namely you're allowed to apply some one
qubit gates and i have sprinkled
throughout these applications of you and
this is the precise set of states that
are allowed in the CFT and that to which
you know there are certain complexity is
conjectured to be dual to their volume
now the evidence you know somewhat
surprisingly quantum gravity theorists
were able to show that actually the
changes to the wormholes volume which
are induced by throwing in these
shockwaves actually exactly matches the
changes of complexity that one jeans
obtains in these states by adding these
one qubit local operator insertions
actually this even holds in a bit more
general model than this where you're
allowed to apply u inverse as well as u
in this kind of time evolution so this
is kind of really surprising when you
first see
and this is really where their evidence
for complexity equals volume is coming
from is that you know like this this
kind of somewhat miraculously
this general relativity calculation of
what happens to a wormhole when you
throw an energy to it ends up kind of
mirroring exactly what happens when you
evolve by some Hamiltonian and insert
some someone cubed operators into the
Hamiltonian evolution and there's a Q&A
sure yeah I just want to ask um okay so
as you know not all circuits are hard to
compute just most of them so how does
this like factor into the theory are
there like corresponding trivial
wormholes whose volume doesn't grow with
time and is it known that these are like
a fraction of all wormholes in 80's so
this is really talking about this
particular state and this particular
type of two-sided wormholes so yes there
are
okay wormholes always have more than one
side by and there are one side that
black holes that do not have this sort
of volumetric like but like for one
sided black holes which are the ones
that form from gravitational collapse
you like the ones we think exist in our
universe these ones you know there is no
other side to it there's just a
singularity on the other side so there
there is no other University you could
you could reach but you know I think
your question though is getting that
kind of an important point is that you
know what's happening here
like the reason that we're limited in
the number of shocks were allowed to
apply to the wormhole you know which is
the number of one qubit gate operations
is because each of these kind of adds
some energy to the wormhole so one's
worried if you threw a lot of energy in
that you could you know completely
distort the geometry all right so this
is why we're limiting ourselves to you
know kind of applying having a very tiny
amount of energy to the system it's it's
not even clear if there is a even a
well-defined geometry on the other side
and if you throw in too much energy yeah
great great yeah thanks thanks for the
question okay so these are the sets of
states that are allowed on the c of t so
the central question we're going to be
asking is you know how hard is it to
estimate the circuit complexity of such
states so we have states in the
following form the question we're going
to be asking is kind of something like
this you know given many copies of the
state of the above form you know how
difficult should it be to estimate its
circuit complexity which here ends up
being roughly the number of times that
that you applied you write you know plus
some tiny correction factor for these
extra one qubit gates now the standard
tool that one would usually turn to to
try to answer this question would be to
try to show that states of this form
form a unitary T design right so if
states are a unitary T design then this
means their information theoretically
indistinguishable from say T copies of a
har random state you know T copies of
these states would be indistinguishable
40 copies of a har random State and that
would immediately imply that the
complexity of these states is hard to
estimate because these states have
little complexity but how random states
have maximal complexity now
unfortunately it turns out that we can't
use this tool in this to address our
question the reason is that the number
of different states we have in our
ensemble of states we're talking about
here is something that's relatively
small it's like four to the L States but
you know L has to be much smaller than
the number of qubits n so we have like a
like think of L as being like n to the
epsilon for a tiny Epsilon whereas on
the other hand there's a very simple
counting argument that says if you want
an ensemble of states to be a 1 design
they are need to be 4 to the n different
elements in the ensemble you kind of
analogous to how the polygroup is a 1
design so in some sense you know we
information theoretic tools will not
work to address this question so instead
to address this question we're going to
use a different technique if we're going
to use the tool
of computational pseudo randomness so
computational pseudo randomness is
basically the computational form of
information theoretic pseudo-random this
where we're going to try to argue that
even though these states are information
theoretically this thing's you will for
random will try to argue that that
information is somehow inaccessible to
limited time computations so fortunately
this notion of quantum computational
pseudo randomness was actually defined
in previous work of Giglio and so on so
in particular the they define this thing
called a quantum pseudo-random state
ensemble or PRS and the definition looks
something like this like you call a
collection of states I K on n qubits
where K is say an N bit bit string think
of K as being your secret key so you
called a collection of these states a p
RS if it has a base of following two
conditions the first is that they're
efficiently prepara Bowl so in other
words you can create each States I K and
polynomial time you know with the
quantum circuit starting from some
reference state and the second is a
computational indistinguishability
criteria which does something like this
like for any polynomial Q of n Q event
copies of the states ik4 a fixed but
random K are not bqp distinguishable
from Q of n copies of a horrendous state
Phi so this is saying that kind of you
know even though our key is of fixed
polynomial size you know even if I gave
you an arbitrary number you know an
arbitrarily polynomial scaling number of
copies of the state you know if you just
had access to efficient quantum
computation you wouldn't be able to
distinguishes it from that many copies
of a horrendous T so this is clearly you
know just the quantum analog of you know
the classical notion of a pseudo-random
function and what's really nice is that
I know
Geely own song and also recent work of
Barsky and
Whaley showed that if showed that there
is a way of efficiently creating quantum
pseudo-random States if you have access
to Universal quantum computer so
particularly they showed something like
this like let's say you have a
pseudo-random function f K of X she'd by
some secret key K then if you consider
the stage which is an equal
superposition over all strings and you
just apply a pseudo-random phase to to
each string then this ensemble of states
is actually computationally
indistinguishable from a harem of states
even with arbitrarily polynomial in many
copies of the state so in other words
you know and so long as you believe that
there is a PRF that's secured against
quantum computers you'll say like you
believe lwe or you there's as long as
there are some one-way function hard
against long computers we know this can
be constructed um then this means that
you believe it is possible with
universal quantum computers to prepare
pseudo-random state ensembles okay this
is really great but you know in some
sense this work doesn't directly help us
so you know the Quantum's the CFT states
that were asked talking about here you
know are not states in which it seems to
be possible to eat to perform universal
quantum computation right like they're
states I in some sense our hands are
really tied with these states all we can
do is apply some fixed unit area U which
is known to everybody and the ply you
know some small number of perturbations
of that evolution so as a result this
means that we cannot use the JLS
construction kind of because the set of
states were talking about here is just
too restrictive
all right so how are we going to get it
around this well instead we're going to
take a very different sort of
inspiration here we're going to take our
inspiration from block ciphers such as
the AES and des crypto systems and we're
going to try to use our intuition from
block ciphers to create a quantum p RS
ensemble with with our very limited
subset of states all right so here's our
soon over
meliss construction being in tuition
this is fairly simple to explain so
alright first let's observe that you
know even though our unitary you which
you know it's scrambling in some sense
like you know it it kind of mixes up the
whole system that the fuses local to
perturbation throughout it you know the
state that you obtained by just applying
many you many times to this initial
state this is not a pseudo random state
so you know how can you see that well
this is because this hamiltonian h c ft
is actually fixed and kind of known to
everyone so as a result if you were
given the state of this form you know
you could just time of all that
backwards to try to you know until you
hit the the initial state in order to
determine the length of the time
evolution so in other words in this
model you know the adversary has the
ability to apply u inverse so it doesn't
make any sense to you know to not add
any perturbations here so the key idea
in our construction is to apply the
shocks to the state you know apply these
one qubit perturbations but don't reveal
them to the adversary so in other words
treat the pattern of shocks it's kind of
the secret key that we're using and our
construction and the basic idea is that
the shocks that you're adding in can
help obscure the length of the time
evolution of your system because it
means that just running u inverse
backwards no longer will get you to your
initial state so that's kind of very
hand wavy so let me formalize this a
little more carefully so let's say we
pick a secret key K which is in the
polygroup so let's say instead of the
secret key K being you know a bit string
of length L let's say it's a string in i
XYZ of length L all right and let's
consider states which are obtained by
alternate alternating applying U and
applying the if' poly operator in the
secret key
and let's just say that we're always
applying those operators to the first
qubit for simplicity the basic idea is
that applying these one qubit operators
these once you make unitary creates kind
of branching points in the evolution of
the system so in other words if you
start with your initial States this TFT
state you know they're now four
different states you could evolve to in
the next kind of step of the evolution
you know and then sixteen going on
etcetera etc so they're end up being
four to the L different states that you
could reach by one of these you know
shock patterns and the basic intuition
is that you know if you were a hard
random then all the states in these
trees would be approximately orthogonal
to one another
alright and what what's the reason for
this you know this is just you know kind
of some sort of simple calculation which
is like you know if you take a hard
random state and you apply a poly X on
the first qubit we know that that
renders the state nearly orthogonal to
itself right this is just a property of
generic States so the claim that we're
making in our paper is that this is a
pseudo random state ensemble essentially
because if I gave you an unknown state
Phi it would be very hard to tell if the
state Phi I handed you is a state that
lies in this tree or not right so what
okay and this is again a bit loose so
let me be even more precise so let's the
way that we argue for security it's an a
simplified black box model so in
particular let's suppose that our
unitary you were truly random you know
later what argue this could be
instantiated in some sort of pseudo
random way but let's just assume it's
truly horror in them for now and let's
imagine that the only access you have to
you is by applying u and u inverse as
black boxes then our claim is that in
this black box model the number of
queries that you need to distinguish a
random psych a
from a truly random state scales
exponentially in Elm right and the
intuitive reason that this is true is
that this effectively just ends up being
some sort of search lower bound the
basic intuition is that if this tree is
relatively shallow and you have a truly
random unitary then all of these states
in the tree are essentially like
independently random states chosen you
know essentially independently random
States chosen from the horror measure
over this distribution because
effectively the tree is too shallow for
you to see any collisions in life so
this is kind of the our evidence for
security and we conjecture that this
security holds in the white box model
where this unit area you you know isn't
truly random but instead that's you know
whatever the scrambling dynamics of the
CFTR and of course you know we can never
prove a conjecture like this and also we
don't even have an explicit description
of a Hamiltonian to work with for the
cfd Hamiltonian but this is the basic
idea of the construction and you know to
see this a little more concretely it's
actually it might be helpful to show a
you know there is a very a much simpler
kind of classical analog of the pseudo
random state construction and I think
that understanding this classical analog
might make understanding this argument a
much more straight or so so the
classical analog is something that I'm
going to call the flip or not block
cipher and you'll see why I'm calling it
this in a second so in this so what this
block cipher is is let's just think of
it as a way of generating string
pseudo-random so let's say that we have
a fixed but random permutation Sigma of
n bit strings and let's take a secret
key a bit string of length L so let's
imagine the following process let's
imagine we start with the string 0 to
the end and then
we apply sigma and then we then
according to the first bit of the secret
key be flipped the first bit of the
string or not you know so if the first
day of the string is one flip the first
bit after this first application of
Sigma and if it's zero do nothing right
and then apply Sigma again and then flip
the first bit of the string according to
the second bit of B etc etc so let's say
that we iterate this L times this is a
particular way of generating strings and
you can see that this looks very
analogous to our quantum pseudo-random
state construction right because these
unitary zru terry's you that are very
scrambling are now replaced by random
permutations and instead of applying
poly operators you know we're just
flipping the first bit of the string now
let's suppose that I gave you a string Y
u one might ask you how hard is it to
tell if Y was either given to you
generated by this process for random bit
string B but you know you don't know the
bit string or or you know why was
uniformly and independently random so as
nothing to do with either Sigma or or B
so it turns out that you can show very
rigorously that if you're only given
black box access to Sigma and Sigma
inverse then you need at least 2 to the
order L over 2 queries to the the black
box for Sigma and Sigma inverse in order
to distinguish you know one of these
random strings YB from a truly random
string right in the intuition here is
exactly as before right like the
intuition is that you know this this
process is generating some sort of tree
of possible strings you could be in and
you know if this tree is shallow enough
that's if L is much less than n then
this tree is basically independently
random strings so it ends up reducing to
a sort of unstructured search box so
this is the black box security statement
that we proved rigorously
and in the quantum setting we sketch a
proof event but we don't give the full
proof because it turns out some of the
details I'm not being quite quite nasty
there but this is kind of the classical
intuition for the pseudo randomness
construction of our scheme and the
question from the Q&A to know do you
have a question I think I didn't
actually answered it the theorem
statement says the Sigma and Sigma
inverse look it would be a black box
axis that was my question thank you
exactly so this is shown in a black box
model think of it like a random Oracle
model yes a random Oracle in this case a
permutation
yeah yeah one thanks well it's probably
we got queries of course we're having
the permutations and random functions or
that's right
thanks yeah Adam I had a kind of basic
question so you maybe you talked about
this earlier so this CFT Hamiltonian you
seem to assume that it's scrambling what
like is this just just believed to be
true or is there some like a principle
reason for why we believe it should be
scrambling yeah that's a great question
so this is something that has been
discussed in physics for a long time but
um there is this thing called the fast
scrambling conjecture which basically
conjectures black holes are the most
efficient scramblers in nature I'd say
this is something that's very highly
believed by the community and you know
kind of the reason that spawns will
maybe go back to kind of Hawking's
original black hole information paradox
which maybe I don't have time to explain
but that's but I'd say this is something
that's very widely believed by it by by
the community you know if given a
suitably rigorous definition of scram of
course there are many different
definitions of scrambling here I'm being
someone intentionally vague here but
that's but the fact that there is some
scrambling behavior it's not something
that I've heard being debated and so so
it would be correct to somehow equate
CFTs with black holes like that somehow
well in some sense like this a DSC ft
picture is trying to give a more
understandable picture of what happens
to a black hole as a kind of game
quantum information as stuff falls into
it and then loses quantum information
through a Hawking radiation so somehow
there's some paradoxes that would come
up if the Hawking radiation
you know if the output of the black hole
which is kind of the ant the analogy to
the the CFT duel if it were not
scrambled then there would be some kind
of immediate paradoxes that would arise
where there'd be a copy of in front of
some info and quantum information both
on the inside of the black hole and kind
of on the outside the black hole
simultaneously and maybe get to how this
kind of fits into our work recently but
if it's kind of scrambling its it could
be a little more plausible because
somehow you got maybe the information is
there but you can never access them but
I'll explain this a little more shortly
sure so yeah but anyways I want to say
that B's kind of flip or not block
cyphers actually look very similar to
block ciphers like AES so if you compare
our construction where you're applying
some permutation Sigma and kind of
applying the first bit of the secret key
and then kind of applying Sigma and then
flying above the secret key you know
this looks very similar to block ciphers
like AES where here they have some kind
of very scrambling permutation of Sigma
but instead of applying the security
kind of one bit of the time they tend to
like XOR in the entire secret key to
every bit of the string at every round
of the block cypher construction so you
can kind of see our pseudo randomness
constructor that we made is kind of like
a block cipher like AE yes but where you
dribble in the secret key one bit at a
time instead of kind of applying it
fully at each round so in this sense you
can kind of think of our result as
giving a kind of fully quantum block
cipher and
some kind of hate waving sense okay so
in shorts yeah so I'm just going to
quickly times summarize with what we
show them the pseudo randomness parts so
in short we argued that these states in
the CFT are plausibly pseudo-random you
know assuming you're you're willing to
make our white box security conjecture
and you know the scrambling nature of
the CFT evolution is what makes our
white box security conjecture plausible
in in this construction that that's
inspired by block ciphers and you know
this pseudo regular statement can be
easily seen to immediately imply that
estimating the length of time evolution
of the dual quantum state is something
that's exponentially hard right to see
this you know you just imagine
instantiating our construction with
different polynomial lengths of time
evolution and you know if each of these
different lengths of time evolution are
indistinguishable from horrendous States
well that means in particular they're
also indistinguishable from one another
as well right so thus endeth ends up
establishing that different
instantiations of our construction would
say wormholes of length N squared verse
and cubed should also be computationally
indistinguishable from from each other
and also you know kind of as I mentioned
earlier this see the randomness argument
shows any quantity that grows linearly
with time of this quantum state is
something that's hard to estimate right
because again if you apply you and
squared versus and cube times you know
this is not something that you can
efficiently distinguish so on the other
hand you know there's the second part of
our paper which is arguing that the
volume of the states is somehow easy to
to feel and I don't have time to get
into us in detail but you know I'll kind
of sketch the argument for you again
it's you know or see the regulus
argument really tells you that giving
even a really coarse estimate of the
volume you know like is it N squared or
n cubed would already be a
to break our pseudo-random this
construction through the dictionary but
you know as I mentioned no one observer
can mention the volumes so our basic
argument is that you know if you create
polynomial a many observers in this
wormhole which are spaced such that kind
of you know if there's a horizon between
them they cannot communicate but with
one another but there if if there is no
horizon then they can communicate with
one another so you just kind of throw a
bunch of observers into the space and
kind of count how many of them were able
to talk to one another then it's quite
clear that kind of post-processing their
outcomes of you know whether they were
able to communicate with their neighbor
ends up giving one a very coarse
estimate to the volume of the wormhole
and an interesting fact to note is that
you know in order to make this argument
that you know we can perform this
post-processing we have to assume a
quantum extended church-turing thesis
for quantum gravity that's because we
have to imagine that you could kind of
separately simulate the experiences of
each each observer with a quantum
computer and then on top of each
simulation kind of apply a polynomial
time post-processing state step what
kind of aggregates their experiences and
then you'll outputs this event which
tells you know what is the volume of the
wormhole smaller large so the fact that
we have to extend the quantum extended
church-turing thesis per gravity is kind
of a very interesting aspect of our
result so you know as I said before you
know this argument implies that the
dictionary is exponentially difficult to
compute there's actually one other way
that you could you know evade our
arguments another possibility that our
humans raised is that it could be that
the quantum extended church-turing
thesis is false in quantum gravity so if
actually the quantum gravity dynamics of
the interior of a wormhole are
exponentially difficult to compute with
a quantum computer then that wouldn't
necessarily be the case
the dictionary hat would have to be hard
to compute because this kind of
simulation of the experiences of the
different observers is an integral part
of our argument so let me just kind of
quickly conclude with the a few kind of
high-level comments as to what our
results might mean for ATS CFT so I
think that the jury is still out here
but there have been kind of a few
different flavors of interpretation of
you know what be pseudo-random the
statements might mean for the feel the
the first flavor is maybe best expressed
in our recent paper of Susskind who
argued in some sense that you know the
complexity of the dictionary you could
think of it as a bug maybe it's not a
bug but it's something that should be
hidden and it's it's something that
should be hidden behind horizons so one
thing to note is that you know in order
to get a contradiction with our theory
you know you have to simulate the
experiences of observers inside the
horizon of the black hole that is to say
observers who jumped in so Susskind
conjectured that you know maybe this is
reflective of a broader trend maybe
there's a form of computational cosmic
censorship in which in our universe any
violations of the quantum extended
church-turing thesis or exponentially
complex dictionaries are only shielded
by horizons that is you know these can I
have pathological computational things
can only occur kind of after you jump
into a black hole and this can be seen
as kind of a computer science analog of
the cosmic censorship conjecture of
Penrose going back to the 60s
conjectured that you know all
singularities in general relatively are
shielded by horizons this is kind of a
computational version of that now
there's another way of viewing this
result and this is maybe best expressed
by a recent paper of kin press : tain
which is you could actually view the
complexity of this dictionary as a
feature rather than the bug so in
particular
this high complexity dictionary might
actually protect causality in these
theories so as I was mentioning before
the inserts are kind Henry's question
you know you might think of this CFP
state as kind of being similar to the
Hawking radiation that was emitted by a
black hole now if you believe in some
kind of holography or some kind of
complementarity picture of black hole
physics then you believe that the
exterior physics of the black hole are
in some sense dual to the interior
physics so there is some whence some
sense in which you know the physics
outside of the black hole and inside the
black hole are related to one another by
some Dictionary and what Kim Cresco
Lintang raised is that well maybe the
fact this dictionaries exponentially
complex is what prevents you from having
you know some lack of causality in your
theory like if maybe if this dictionary
were too simple then someone could
manipulate kind of the boundary theory
or in the Hawking radiation that with
it's very far from the black hole in
order to manipulate the interior of the
black hole which is far far away you
know and that would be something that
would be seen this kind of pathological
in the theory so it could be that this
that this that this high complexity
Dictionary is actually something that
that might be helpful or beneficial to
ATS CFT and finally you know there's
this question about you know what when
the quantum extended church-turing
thesis mean for quantum gravity you know
we kind of use this extended
church-turing thesis as a black box to
say we can simulate the experiences
observers but you know formulating this
if it were rigorously is something that
I think is you know could be a really
interesting problem to work on you know
and would require answering problems
like you know how does this this quantum
gravity state encode the geometry of
this theory and so it you know there's
some interesting physics questions there
and there also some interesting computer
science questions there and to how you
formalize computation in a relativistic
theory so yeah so that's that's it for
my presentation for today thanks so much
for
for your penguin attention all right
thank you very much out of those a super
interesting talk yeah so people please
have any questions so you can type it
into the Q&A or or the chat John would
like to react this question from earlier
yeah yeah sorry yeah I just got a little
confused basically okay as I understand
it there's this connection between
wormhole volume and like the circuit
complexity and kind of intuition is that
well a circle complexity as you as you
apply this unitary T times the
complexity grows key which is similar to
the wormhole volume which also grows by
T but you know it's basically the case
that like most circuits are difficult to
compute but some of them you know a
small fraction of them are easy to
compute and I was curious how this
factors into the theory well my
understanding it's like you you want
you're thinking about this sort of
unitary you may be as you apply it t
times the circuit complexity grows
linearly with that's not something that
would happen for all unitary views of
course yeah how does that how does that
is there some sort correspondence on
like the wormhole volume side that's
natural oh that's a great question so I
I I'm not sure that the dictionary is as
well worked out as maybe you're thinking
here and in the in the following sense
I'm not sure that you know for it I
think what there actually is this
there's one fixed Hamiltonian that
they're really talking about on each
side so I'm not sure that there is
necessarily freedom to consider
different Hamiltonians on one side
versus the other here if that makes any
sense
see you're saying there's like it's not
like there are any Hamiltonian
they're just like one Universal worst
one and they think it should be
scrambling in some way I see that's and
okay so we're working with that now
again there has been this complexity
theoretic work that I alluded to of
Aronson and brandão LaDonna wicks who
showed that you know if you somehow you
know encodes the steps of some Universal
you know cellular automata or something
like this then you know after some
exponential amount of time you should be
able to do P space in this model so
unless P space is equal to B Q P then
you know there should be some super
polynomial growth over time you know
that those are kind of the flavors of
the sorts of complexity theory evidence
that's been provided so far to so but
those are all saying like here are some
super specially constructed Hamiltonian
let me show that it's plausible that
complexity grows here but you know
there's not like an explicit Hamiltonian
that they have written down for you to
ask you know that says Hamiltonian meet
this criteria or not okay thanks yeah
you want me to comment briefly on that
yeah sure sure
I think okay I mean I mean I think it
you know getting the complexity growth
is actually a pretty generic property
you know these Hamiltonian is in
particular like basically anything that
is sort of computationally universal you
know we could use it in our argument so
sort of anything that can you know such
that sort of simulating its evolution
over an exponential number of steps is a
pspace-complete problem right yes that's
like a pretty generic property of
dynamical systems right now we know that
some property has to be need I mean just
as John was saying like if we had a zero
Hamiltonian that did nothing well it's
never going to generate any complexity
right so you do need something about the
Hamiltonian also something about the
initial state that it's acting on but I
think the eigen state or something yeah
you know and it's very actually it's
very much related to what to read and
Yosi idea called the no fast forwarding
property in a few years ago right and
you know and there can the conjecture
that they made
like if you take a generic Hamiltonian
it should not be fast forward a bull
that is it should not be there should
not be an efficient I predict what it
will do after an exponential amount of
time and you know and basically you know
we just you know you know I I agree with
their conjecture that sort of most
Hamiltonian should be non fast forward
of both you know you could say because
of being computationally universal there
the FT Hamiltonian has these properties
is a little unclear but I guess one
might argue well it should be capable of
you know some form of universal quantum
computing so presumably it has a
universal a University property along
these lines right yeah I mean I mean you
could say that maybe anything that is so
simple that these results wouldn't apply
to it is maybe also so simple that it
would not be a good model for our
universe yeah yeah it might not be rich
enough to capture the physics that they
want yeah yeah yep yeah yeah thanks
thanks for the comment
question from Isaac Kim Isaac yeah so I
wrote it up already but I'll just repeat
it so when you argue that the wormhole
volume is easy to compute how would this
conclusion change if the number of
observers you can put in the wormhole is
like little ole then and I asked this
question because if you have sort of too
many observers you end up like injecting
too too much energy into the wormhole
which may actually change the underlying
geometry yeah so oh you know we don't
actually need any math or you know any
we don't need a physical observer there
we just need some way of kind of
measuring whether you know some photon
reach some state you know reach
someplace or something like this and
there's no need for all the experiments
to happen simultaneously as well so I so
I don't think this this would
necessarily be a barrier to the argument
you just have to would imagine doing the
experiment pairwise rather than throwing
them in all all at once right so this
would just blow up the number of copies
of the state you need but then you
wouldn't actually need to you know
instantiate all of them in one copy of
the state so yeah there could be some
trade-offs here between the number of
copies of the wormhole states you need
to estimate the volume and the number of
observers you throw in okay thanks yeah
yeah and of course as I mentioned
earlier if the state actually just
encodes some global geometry then then
you don't even need this argument right
so it's it's somewhat depends on how
strong of a complementarian you are in
terms of believing you can only
reconstruct single observers experiences
thanks yeah thanks any other questions
okay so if not you know thanks Adam and
thanks to all the speakers of today's
session and yeah I think today was
pretty successful I think we averaged
around like 80 years old participants
throughout the day so that's pretty
awesome and we'll continue tomorrow at
9:00 a.m. Pacific time so for tuning in